we did it
we beat t series 269
i never been more proud i never actually
felt a [ __ ] of respect for you guys but
god damn it you pulled through but i
just realized
i made a huge mistake getting 69 million
subscribers
isn't the most important number that
exists that's right i'm talking about
six nine six nine six
nine six nine subscribers and
a collab with takeshi six nine so boom
i'm with two people boom boom boom boom
boom boom
i'm leading the show cause you know for
sonic means
what's
what does that mean like like an act
that's when we know we have done it
that's when i can throw in the towel and
be like
stop take the spot t series i don't care
six nine six nine six nine
six nine six nine million subscribers
can we
hit it please it will be the last thing
i ask you
now let's just jump into the memes guys
when pewds hits 69 million and brings
back bonus meme
all in the same day you guys are the man
or women or whatever you are no
discrimination
see ya marcia when all 7.5 million
subscribers
are saying so she got as many views as
subscribers oh it looks like
he's crying too hey uber eats i'm doing
my part
from bangladesh covered up three
kilometers
jesus christ thank you we have people
working from the inside
this is perfect i never been more proud
indian bros now a lot of people have
been saying oh it's like an
india versus t-series no that has never
been the case
maybe a little bit this is what we need
to do we need more people
working from the inside it's funny
actually a friend of mine sent me
from london this is not from reddit this
is a friend that sent it to me
i appreciate the comic sans great choice
this is how we will win
it's not over yeah we need an
investigation
t-series pewdiepie viewers watch this
kowalski
analysis i should just review it and get
done with it
although bros analysis the perfect
balanced meme does not
exist wow i don't know what to say i
don't know what to say
perfect sequels don't exist zero
subscribers speckle
one subs yes dane thanks his first
subscriber
his grandma but what does the one
subscriber speak out
at least he don't use bots god damn
right
maybe that's what we need to do we need
to broaden the nine-year-old demographic
everyone go ask your grandma to
subscribe right now
if you haven't asked your grandma yet
i'm waiting
this video will not continue hopefully
no one made this joke yet yeah well if
someone already made the joke
practically but it's a good it's a good
one my sister drew pewds in colored
pencil i want him to see it
beautiful this is incredible art but
where are all the texts
where are all the info saying subscribe
to pewdiepie what is this
some kind of joke don't waste my time
bought a small ad space
see this is what i'm talking about you
bought you bought a local newspaper and
published it
help pewds be the first one to reach 69.
this is how we reached our goal
we worked together god damn it i'm proud
i'm actually proud
made some [ __ ] lasagna that actually
looks good
that honestly looks like a delicious
base lasagna
when we hit 69 69 69 69
69 million subscribers i'll personally
deliver
this lasagna to t series smart guys
saying that girls can't be gamers
saying girls can't be video games so the
media won't
be able to quote him on it i mean yeah
it's like you have to make it
so blatantly obvious if you make a joke
these days you can't just say
girls aren't gamers oh my god i can't
believe he said that
doesn't matter if it was a joke so yeah
you got it congratulations you figured
me out what are you gonna do huh
turn me into the media doesn't matter
i'm not scared please don't please don't
turn me into me please
when you see big lasagna got removed
from spotify
yeah someone else keeps re-uploading it
it's not my fault
just let you know it's not my fault
waves don't care about your sand castle
and clearly not mr ben shapiro either
if we beat t-series i will bring back
bonus meme
that's right oh well it did came back
that's right
what can i say i'm a humble leader i'm a
humble king
if you guys deliver so do i
remember six nine six nine six nine six
sections nine with takeshi six nine
no not november you not you lose
oh you're not swedish or you don't
understand you dumb ball
of balls you dumb you're just dumb
one down two to go okay this meme review
was epic if we can get dr phil or elon
musk
or takeshi 69 or literally anyone
that would be epic is this tracer yep
and no one currently has tracer yep
so anyone could choose tracer makes
sense to me
so then i'll be tracer i'm already
tracer
this is why women aren't in video games
the devil exists
god satan okay i've seen
picture i gotta find this video it's
like a t-series
mr beast edition how much are they
paying you simon
how much are they paying you to do this
simon
join us whatever a t-series is paying
you i'll double it
please simon we need more people working
on the inside
next meme i am black and
hereby give you know this is not gonna
be good pewdiepie
and pass renewal which lets him justify
any time he said the n-word in the past
this now makes what he said at the
british
i expect to see season 2 of scare
pewdiepie
soon nice try t series nice try but i'm
not falling for it
saw a potential me format on his twitter
felix having a wide screen behind him
could be a new meme format
exclusive to the subreddit yeah you're
right i didn't think about that when i
posted it oh no
what have i done upgrade perfect oh my
god
never wanting to do that again conan
o'brien
pewdiepie okay theirs is a good meme i'm
willing to give it one more shot
just one more shot for you have sinned
for not being a subscriber to my child
pewdiepie
for he needs our help to banish t-series
from youtube
for once and for all it seems to be
that's t-series
made a deal with satan to become number
one
so smash that subscribe button hit the
bell for notifications and spread the
good news
for pewdiepie will remain as number one
if we succeed i will forgive all your
sins
oh wow i'd like to bless valencia
and anishito for sending their regards
jesus joins the team now there's no way
we can lose
people spamming sub to pewdiepie on
league of legends world stream
oh that's awesome this is the power
of everyone working together and doing
one part their part
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter if
you're a loser that never leave your
computer
and just haven't done anything with your
life you now finally have a chance
to do something meaningful god damn it
found a computer at work with someone's
google account logged on
so i did that person a favor and smashed
subscribe you didn't hit the bell button
what are you thinking am i supposed to
be thankful
now do it right and do it again oh wait
what is this
romania
[Music]
wow i'm doing my part
hey i'm
[Music]
i didn't know they had tape in romania
mad lada everyone what an
absolute medal at it very proud thank
you
i think i think me and dr phil needs to
feel each other if you know what i mean
do you watch pewdiepie
no i don't i won't judge but can you sub
to him so he can stay number one you are
the second guy who has said this to me
oh lord well then subscribe already it's
not that hard
it's really not that hard that looks
like markiplier
oh markiplier not looking good these
days oh my god that's weird
why mark you can't just go around
stealing books
oh i wish i saw that that is amazing
that's how you know she's white we made
history 69 million you're god damn right
we did
but it's not over yet we're so close god
damn it
so close i can taste it now go out there
tell your grandma
and do your part thank you for watching
this video
thank you for all the memes and thank
you for all the amazing support
but most of all thank you for 69 million
subscribers
you did your job so here's your room
oh okay
all right move on get the ass outro
please
[Music]